this train is just arrived from the
Hungarian Serbian border we're now at
head guess Shalom Station in Hungary and
these hundreds of refugees have gotten
off and they're about to walk to the
Austrian border we're gonna go with them
they've been on this road since
September 5th it's now September 15th 10
days straight obviously they're really
tired there's only been like a day or
two of rest I'm gonna kill Tina Lincoln
hey hey look look I am Surya here here
gonna do mm I have to do a manual and
and that's it to a CD you know to
joseline for Jonathan a Dickens dr.
Harad and karate no dr. rivela hired
nine-year career owaru from Carter who
again is a lifetime a slow develop
Charlie for Chelsea any sub didn't you
click no Isla well I'm a new girl
oh hello Daniel II will do CLE the Lenny
Terry Marshall mr. Sharon I'm hoping
that I hear a lot of people many many
people come today
how many that today what are you guys
doing out here
are we just distributing some food to
the refugees and try to contribute our
part to humanity and such and you see
people I'm like wait so we're
approaching the border right now this is
the border with Austria hello Jenny this
is Roland
I definitely motion that is McKinley
a little candy we stopped over there to
talk to those people who are really
eager to tell us their stories then we
lost our friends that we were walking
with so we're gonna walk over there to
that tent maybe they went over there
let's go run Hey
I love never do comfortable in its own I
was at the kids get to the microphone
the horn
cinema Angela very excited I are gonna
play separate on everything by opening a
committee they went off in a cab 250
euro straight to Vienna they're so
relieved right now and they feel like so
much of the difficult journey is over
but the question we ask now is for
people in their shoes what next